[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Megan is
with us Hi Megan how are you I'm doing
fantastic thank you so much for taking
my call I greatly appreciate and it's an
absolute honor to speak to both of you
today you too what's up um so I have a a
quick question it's um I have a
brother-in-law who is being completely
enabled by my mother-in-law and
father-in-law he is currently still
living at home he's almost 40 years old
and he has some uh he has a drug
addiction problem as well as he's
currently not working and my major
concern is that you know my my in-laws
are getting older they're almost 80 um
and we recently purchased a house and it
has a complete separate in-law suite um
they kind of their eyes kind of got a
little bit big when they saw the new
house that we purchased for ourselves
and they made mention like oh isn't this
just a lovely place for you guys to
potentially rent out later down the line
kind of hinting at the fact that
potentially um the brother could
potentially move in with us how do I
Polly explain to them I have zero desire
of him moving into our house you don't
your husband does it's his mother not
yours absolutely I agree with you your
husband have a backbone or does he need
to run down to Walmart and pick one up I
think I need to buy him one for
Christmas okay I'll three I'll three at
Walmart I'll three yeah yeah so appar
listen if you if you do it you're gonna
be the Wicked Witch of the West until
they
die okay because one thing about
enablers they don't think they're
enablers they think they're
nice and if you don't participate in
their enabling by definition you are not
nice so you see this with very very
clear eyes your husband does your
husband agree with you I'm not kidding
does your husband needs to head this off
at the pass what's what's what's
brother's name first name Joe Joe Joe
good okay so brother just catches you
know m m and Papa at the at the dinner
table and says hey just to let you guys
know uh Joe's not moving in with us as
long as I'm
breathing that's her husband's
job okay you don't say a word you sit
there and just kind you sit there and
kind of dab the corners of your eye like
you're
crying okay you don't say a word what
was the question Megan there's no way to
what for me to politely bring this up no
no why do you keep going back to you do
you you have to do it because I have the
backbone I know but you can you can
share yours with
him my wife does it all the time she
says sick
them that is true that is true well in
Stacey's case too she's a sweetest she
can be but but she makes it very clear
what her position is on some things at
times and and it that means means it's
clear that I need to get on that page
yeah you don't have a brother-in-law
problem you have a husband problem
that's exactly right so do you pick
those up at Walmart 2 new ones or I do
that that's a whole separate call yeah
no I mean to get with Dr John delone
your marriage counselor or whatever else
but I honestly I would just say honey if
I talk to your mom about this this is
not going to go well they're going to be
angry with me and I don't want that it
is your family it's actually your job
and uh I'm going to encourage you uh I'm
going to give you a stiff cup of coffee
a stiff kick in the rump and you're
going to go talk to your mother and dad
and at some point when it comes up
gently and be kind and just say you know
you don't want to be as rough as I was a
minute ago but just Mom and Dad look
we've got this house and I you know you
guys were all big eyed about the moving
about you know us having an apartment to
rent we might rent it out someday but we
won't be renting it out to Joe yeah and
you need to know that ahead of time and
Joe you know I go and tell Joe Joe
you're not moving in I love you but I
hate what you've become and I'm not
going to participate in your drug
addiction your laziness and your
parasitical involvement with Mom and Dad
you're a parasite you need to you need
to you know I I'll help you I'll coach
you I'll love you and help you get up on
your feet and actually become a man and
go be somebody but you ain't living in
my house
dude okay and that's your husband's
job 100% of the time that you say one
word or even agree using your eyes
you're going to get blamed for this
don't let this land on you it's not your
fault okay make him do it he he can do
it cuz he does agree with you but he
comes from enablers which are nice
people and they build a family script
that anyone that goes against nice
people is by definition mean people and
that's that's running around in your
husband's head M am I
wrong no you're not wrong yeah and
you're not mean and you're not crazy and
you're not you know you are sweet and
you're being protective of your own home
space which you should be this is called
Boundaries and when you set up
boundaries for people that don't have
any they generally don't like it so you
don't need to be the one doing it create
your free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life